Okay, good
morning. We're
live. So, here's the plan for
today. The latest version of Puffer Lib
is doing very, very well on isolated
runs uh on a number of different
environments. We've set soda in the past
3, four weeks on pretty much everything
and by a huge margin. Uh the only last
few things blocking are just a few
technical errors. We pretty much have
not run a fresh hyperparameter sweep in
like a good couple of months on any of
these things. So there's probably can
even do way better than it's doing now.
We just have some technical issues
preventing that. Um specifically we have
runs crashing
uh due to like nans and imps. Torch
should not be crashing with nans and
imps. Those should just be, you know,
nanner and floss. That should not
actually crash Torch. Uh the lazy fix on
this would be to just throw everything
into a subprocess. I don't want to do
that. So instead, we're going to
actually go through the transcript
today. We're going to figure out why
we're getting ns and imps on stuff and
yeah, we're going to go from there.
Switch the view over.
indeed. Let's just get ourselves set up
here. I think we actually have some
errors to check
potentially. Yeah. So this one right
here, I mean it's not going to give us
very much information other than just uh
policy gradient loss just
crashed. It is a multinnomial
kernel. So I suspect that this is not
actually in
uh the policy gradient loss. It's
probably in the sample function unless
something else internally has
multinnomial.
I guess cross entropy probably
internally has
it. This could also just be like a
pietorch versioning difference in like
what errors and what doesn't as
well. To be clear, we're not trying to
make it we're not trying to make it like
not fail runs because if you have bad
hypers of course the loss will explode.
Um we just want it to not crash, right?
We want it to knock CUDA error
out. What this gives
us? Yeah, this is just giving us on loss
backwards. It's the same error
everywhere in either in nan or element
less than zero.
Which one was this? This is puffer grid.
This one's going to be
slow. This one will probably I can I
just run this on CPU and get like a
better error message.
Maybe I think that this should still run
at like a reasonable enough
Crazy. This is a thousand or 100x faster
than uh most academia even on
CPU. 250K. That's a quarter million step
per second training with the CNN and
LSTM on
CPU. That's
ridiculous. Okay, so we'll see. I'm
going to just put this on the other
monitor for a
bit and we will uh we'll see how that
does and then in the meanwhile
here we will take a look at
uh not this we'll take a look at the
code
itself and we will see if we can spot
anywhere where uh we've done a bad
multinnomial the only place I can think
of is in the sampling function
though. So I mean the only place we
explicitly have a multinnomial that gets
called is right here,
right? I guess I don't remember whether
I added
Let's try to like get a setup that that
uh reliably triggers this error on our
local while we're running other stuff,
right? If I just set the learning rate
to something
ridiculous, like what if I just set the
learning rate to like 10x higher, it
should instantly crash, right?
Okay. Interestingly, this
doesn't instantly
crash. It doesn't frame, but it doesn't
instantly crash.
What setting could there possibly have
been
then? That's
bizarre.
Okay, let's
try let's see if we can check hyper
prams from one of these like failed
runs. It like crashed on this,
right? So, we should just be able to
look at like hypers for this
maybe. We didn't even full sweep
size
and 32k
mini. Do we think that does it?
Is it
20 97? Whoops.
loss. This doesn't really tell me
anything. And the losses look fine,
though.
fine. I'm trying to think how we
reliably trigger this
like
here five max
crab.
See, that should blow up, right?
The fact I can't break this even if I
try is a little
ridiculous. It doesn't look like it's
logging KL.
It's not logging KL, is
it? Oh, it
I guess instead of doing this, I could
like go set a few different things to
infern and and see if I can break stuff
that way.
So, I can't break it like
this, which is surprising that it's that
stable.
me
mask. Where does it error?
probabil. Okay, so this gives me the
same error
here. And then if I do
train.device. Yeah. So there's
multinnomial and then we
Okay. Interestingly, we still have
this.
This is supposed to be plus not
times boolean
No. Okay. Okay. So now we get in sample
logits we get
errors. What is the correct way to do
this?
I don't think this is
enabled by default.
Huh. It does seem like something is off
here.
I I don't remember Torch ever doing
this. Like this feels like something
changed, right? You know, you used to
get like Nan loss or whatever.
Max
logic. This doesn't
work with nan.
Well, I guess technically the other
thing we could try to do is we could try
to detect
this and we could try to end the run.
numb. Wait.
Nan pause
in. Okay. Wait. They have a thing for
this.
replaces nan positive infinity and
negative
infinity. Okay, that's
good. I didn't know that this function
exist
existed. So we have to do
this only before action
sampling. I think other losses like KL
should be fine, right?
distributions nor uh okay distributions
we handle
these cross entropy obviously uses it in
softmax
operations. Well, I guess we'll see
whether this is stable,
right? But yeah, let's start with uh
let's start with this for sure.
none. So it's 0
0 like
this and then
[Music]
multi. Yeah, this is the only
multinnomial
here. So we do
be
props? What does logistics to props do?
sigmoid. I think we want to do negative
infinity, don't
we? And then this here is going to be a
little different. So,
contains. Okay, so this still
somehow messes up.
I thought that you can put this into
logistics to props.
I thought you could put this into
logistic props.
No. Oh, actually this is my fun. Is this
my
function? No, this is not portrait
distribution.
Oh, it's just a soft
max. Well, that's dumb. We don't need to
have. We need to have this,
right? We can totally replace
this. And then what is it? Soft
max. Okay, I got to go do stuff for like
10 minutes. I'll be back and uh we will
continue fixing this. I'm going to leave
stream on. I'm just going to mute the
mic. Don't let me forget to unmute it.
Be back soon.
here.
Let's fix this bug.
Is that a CrossFit gym with a desktop
and 4090s in the back? Not
quite. This is the puffer training
facility. It is where I train agents and
where I train myself.
Uh, the equipment is not all here yet.
There's much much more coming. For now,
I just
have I've got
the the rack with the fun pull-up bars,
got the climbing rope, got the log for,
the bench, and then I've got the uh the
comp bench in the back. We're getting
uh I think in a week or so, we're
getting a bunch of new bars and some
like nice accessory things. And then
there are four commercial grade pieces
of equipment that'll show up in about a
month. Plus, I got to get um I got a
quote from a bunko for dumbbells. I got
to get a full dumbbell set as
well. Now, the one desktop, that's a
little trickier. We're going to get 40
of those, but not until the tariffs come
down because I'm not playing paying plus
40% for
desktops. But yeah, then we will get 40
of them and then uh the majority of them
will be allocated to like all the open
source stuff that Puffer does. So
ideally we are able to provide compute
for a bunch of contributors, people who
are interested in doing RL work with us.
Uh all free all open
source. I mean we already do that now.
We have uh 10 of them total at the
moment. Only one of them is here. The
other ones are in Florida. But uh
yeah. Oh, and also that one in the back
is not 4090. That one's a 5090.
heck interesting way to spend seed
funding. There's no seed
The
um the gym equipment is not puffer
stuff, right? That's just my personal
stuff. Um the machines will be on uh
puffer. Uh you know, we're doing pretty
well so far. Like we have revenue. Uh 40
bucks is a big ask. So some of that will
also be from my personal um like I'm
going to be spons uh spotting some of
that. But uh you know at the current
rate we should be definitely more than
breaking even on that this year.
So big expense but we're doing all right
with
it. I specifically did not want to get
seed funding so I don't have strings
attached to what I can do, right? Like
I'm really big on all the open source
work. I want to keep like you know as
soon as you start talking to VCs they
say, "Oh yeah, open core. Yeah, it's
good." It's like, yeah, open core. Like,
they want you to make some
non-opensource stuff separate. Like, no,
it's all open source just there. There's
what it is. And uh this is just a much
better way to build things.
Apparently, you can't
just I thought you could put negative
infinities into um into a soft
max. Oh, I guess you can't put all
negative
infinities into a soft max. Is that the
problem?
If we do like
logets zero.
props. Okay, so this
actually that actually
works. So I guess you can't have all
names in there.
I guess multinnomial doesn't need
probabilities either though. What
happens if you put zeros into
multinnomial sum of probability is less
than equal
zero. So
um we just do this directly in prob
space
maybe if we do
like yeah here bot uh if we do this
directly in prob
space. Let me make sure I block the
right. Yeah good.
Torch.num nan to
num probs 0 0
0 and um I guess what we'll do is
instead of doing zeros we'll do
like 1 e minus 8 or
here.
Okay. See if this is
stable. All right. So now this is
correct. All the losses are nans here.
Um but this is what we want. We wanted
it. So if you have nans it should not
crash.
Now, if I run this on
CUDA, does it still not
crash? Perfect. So, I think that this
should be good. I think we should be
good with
this. You see, I explicitly put this
infant there.
Let me make sure it's still
trans. Oh, we also want to do the same
thing in um we want to add like an
epsilon or something
to the pyro maybe.
pyro. There's this like normalization
operation,
like abs
+ 20 - 6 or thing.
right. So, uh, this one here actually
hasn't crashed yet, though. Like, it's
running 10x slower, so it would take 10x
longer to crash. Anyways, uh what we'll
do for
train and we'll hope that this
actually Oh, yeah. I forgot I did a
whole bunch of refactoring at the same
time that I didn't account for.
Uh, you know, I was like waiting for
these experiments to come back, so I
just I did some refactoring and I broke
some stuff.
Okay, so now it
works. I will uh wait for one experiment
before
I before I fully set up the new ones on
this one as
well because we're going to do two boxes
worth of experiments.
This is not up to date. Oh, this is the
same
Okay. So, uh you can see the result of
the latest refactor here. Deleted three.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine. Nine files. added one file
minus 500 lines. Good
refactor. This seems to run stably
enough.
So, we will just go ahead and run our
experiment. And uh now we will have
breakout sweep and maze sweep both
running.
T-Moxes. Make sure I haven't missed any
DMs. Set myself an alarm for
uh meeting later
Uh hopefully this is
fixed. We will see
shortly. Uh what we should expect to
happen
here. So I have this set up in Neptune.
A whole bunch of these
runs. And see here we have three runs
that have just gone on this set. And
then there's one run on this set so far.
If I just like click this tab
here, I you know move some
things then we see this is the initial
run. The initial run is using the center
point of the search distribution. So
it's meant to give you like a reasonable
starting point and then it's going to
take a while after that for to find uh
to figure out some good parameters to
sample. Uh actually there's some
corrections we can make I think to
sweeps as well. There's some things I
want to try with this. Um, but then
yeah, we will have these running
throughout the day and we will see what
else there is uh to work on for the
release. I'm going
to difference between Neptune and Wani.
Uh, so far I've been liking Neptune
more. I've been using it for the past
few months. Puffer lip supports both. I
really like how you can just define
dashboards with like different groups of
plots and then you can apply this
dashboard view to any of the different
groups of plots that you have here. Like
it's really easy to make these nice
views and to do my analysis. It's quite
nice. It's also more performant overall.
All right, back into and just get a
little bit of exercise in here. what the
equipment is for. And uh we will think
about what we do what we do next.
So far so
good.
Now, there's one thing I want to look at
on the sweeps real
quick. Yeah. So this cost thing here I'm
not appending
cost. So what's what's this actually
doing for cost time
linear. Oh, so this is just not going to
I
see. Yeah, this will totally mess up
sweeps. It's a good thing I caught this
because the sweeps probably run stably
now. But
um yeah, this is not going to work well.
So the way that the uh the sweeps work,
we take the trajectory. So we basically
we take this plot that we that we see
from training, right? And the way the
puffer sweep algo works, we cut this up.
We like down sample it to 10 points
instead of however many points are on
this graph. And then we pass those 10
points to a learned model. So it maps
like this number of h this number of
step training steps with these
hyperparams to that level of
performance. Um so it's not getting all
those numbers right now. So, I guess
what we doing right now, we will fix
that. And then once we fix that, we'll
figure out what else to do on uh
optimizing today. A whole bunch of
pre-release work to do.
I don't remember
why. I guess because the profile doesn't
have uptime anymore.
this. We'll just do
cost.append that
Oh, there's also just Hang on. I can
just do
uptime as part of the train run, which
would be better, right? I can just not
even have this.
I can just do data that is it clean
puffer
here. Time minus start
time. It should be fine.
Let's add this to breakout and let's see
if it does anything different.
Okay, so this is what we were getting
initially and we should actually see a
pretty big difference
um because it's like it's very difficult
for it to learn well the the hyperparam
sweep can't really learn anything. It
becomes closer to a random search uh
without that additional arg.
Let's just see how well it was
doing. We're still finding some
stuff. Uh but I think we should expect
it to do substantially better than
this. Yeah, we should expect
substantially better
uh
results. Just making sure that I didn't
break
fine. This
window, same thing.
something 2.2 mil per
model. All right. So that should be
sweeps uh fixed and if not we will find
that out later when we get uh some
actual know some substantial results
back from
list. So the um kind of the name of the
game for the next few weeks is going to
be prepare for release.
Um, so no really new big features going
in at the moment. Just like trying to
polish up everything that we have. Uh,
deliver some really nice baselines, make
it really easy to use, do any last
little performance
tweaks. That's kind of the
idea. My hope is that this block doesn't
take too long and then, you know, we're
able to get this release out within the
next couple of weeks. It's a lot of work
and it's a lot of quite boring work
frankly as well. But um the idea is once
I finish this block so once we do this
release which is going to be uh mostly
like
cleanup benchmarking
uh doing the packaging you know the
refactor and packaging and then writing
the blog post and stuff for release.
Once we get all that done and we have
this out, then the next block for the
next uh probably like a month or
whatever is going to be some hardcore
algorithm development. It's going to be
uh pretty much going back through
everything that DeepMind has done over
the last five years and trying to see
what they figured out and uh how we can
like leverage what works and toss what
doesn't.
Okay.
So, layer norm, we tried that. Let's
just go through everything. Why not? Uh,
layer norm, we tried. It sometimes
works, it sometimes doesn't. It's not a
clear win. Value function batch
norm. Norm not over many. Yeah, we could
actually mess with a few small things
here.
Okay, retune batch size. We're doing
that
now. Basic model architecture scaling.
We did that. It works. Analing
gamma. We didn't really mess with this
and we're not going to do that this
release. Harder algorithm stuff is going
to be for next
segment. Fix dumb end bindings. We
did transpose obs. We tried this. It
didn't. We didn't need to do it. We just
profile ordering. We did this. Compile
and AMP shenanigans. We did this really
clean multi benchmarking. I need to make
a script for that. Still all M's a
normalized score. We did
it. Run script to do all runs under one
tag. Yeah, this is the same thing as
this. We'll do that. Mean cross scores.
This will work as soon as that's done.
Uh, this needs ablations but is
done. This needs ablations but is done.
This is done.
Done. This is the same as this. We kind
of did everything
else. We do need to run some tests on
distributed
running and preset does.
Okay. And then the rest of this is
remove some some old files and
functions. Mostly done. I think there's
only maybe some stuff in PyTorch we can
find, but I think we mostly got rid of
redundant stuff. We do have to go like
make Atari and all the other M's work.
Merge small files into puffer lib. We
did lip range for continuous policy. So
we found that out the other day. We have
not done this yet.
And then there's some notes to add.
Cool. Oh, and I forgot to mention docs.
Yeah, we still need to do new docs for
the new release as well. So, that's
going to be a
pain. I think that the best thing we can
do right now is to start getting some of
the other M's working cuz uh you know, I
probably broke some bindings and stuff
with those and uh meta needs to still
work. That's a big end. And probably
later today, Spencer will be around and
uh Spencer will want to take a look at
GPU drive as well. Try to make that work
for him. Got impulse wars from Captain.
I think that pretty much there two
things that we have other than like the
final
experiments. The two things we have, we
need to clean up little bits of the
training code here and there and then we
need to get like good benchmarks on all
the M's. Once train code is clean and we
have good benchmarks, I will be
comfortable running final experiments
and shipping. So those are the two
things start with
work. Actually, let's just upgrade.
Let's just like do the full upgrade on
this right now.
So, uh, this is one of the keys we're
looking at
here. It's this like kind of
factorioesque. Not really. It's like the
agents collect resources, then they put
them into converters and get other
resources, so on and so forth.
311. That
it. Oh yeah, they made this script a
whole bunch simpler it looks
like. You must be in the metaconda m to
run this. God damn it. They made
required.
sucks.
Huh? Can I just like do these
independently?
27? That's just going to break. Why? Why
is it doing this?
They have this like specified in
requirements. Oh, they have freaking
torch RL in here which then pins
So they don't have meta in here at all,
right?
Metagrid.sh. Okay. So this has
separate I see. So they didn't actually
move it into one package.
Yeah. So, they didn't actually fully
port this at
all. They just like put it into the
Um, tons of
these. This doesn't have requirements
listed at all.
us. We can just use this as
is. Looks like we're going to have to
rewrite this and see this. The thing is
this is kind of
already in uh Python and
C++. But yeah, absolutely. I could make
this thing way faster and simpler.
We have a good collaboration with the uh
the folks that make this. Um the one
tricky thing is just the way that we
tend to build stuff is very very
different. They have like a very big
step big tech style approach to doing
things where like everything is highly
modularized. Um and Puffer is the exact
opposite. We like really try to just
like contain
everything like as much as possible to a
few simple components which are even
intended to just read the source code
of. They're not meant to be
abstracted. But we've basically what
we've done is we've done our best to
like make these things cross-co
compatible in a way that they can build
in the way that they want to build and
we can build our stuff in the way that
we want to build and you know we can
still ship them useful things and then
you know we can still use their end in a
way that's useful for testing.
I think we're going to have to do the
new API port as well,
right? Uh, that is this one's on me. I
got to fix this.
Okay.
So, right, I put numbum M's and num I
put all this stuff into vec, not into
that. Make end from Yeah. So now this is
where we have to do the
port make M from config. And I think
this is where we have to
like see how they did it.
They should have some like scripts or
whatever.
I'm just going to check this on their
web UI. There's like too much stuff to
even look
at. Is it
tools? I think it is
tools. So then they do
Omega
though. Set up meta
n set up
metag. Set up
util runtime configuration.
set up metag of
config. So I think we can just
Yeah, this doesn't even return to an
end.
end? They
don't. So they get
train and then train is
this. So they do load the
Is it somehow in puffer like their
puffer
config. So they have config from path
here.
Where does the end like where do they
actually make the
Oh, I guess it's literally they just
pass they just pass the config
to the end,
right? Okay. Okay. So then all I need to
know is how they load it, which I think
I saw already.
I think it is just
nomeg.load,
right? So I can I just do
that? But can I just do like n equal or
config equals
Omega. Okay. And then you load
this. And then where is
the end
creation thing?
it's from
Metagrid Metagrid N. import Metagrid
N. This takes an N config.
And then this should probably
go after
this. I don't
know. We'll do this for now.
Okay, this is a Python 311
issue. Um, I knew I was going to have to
fix this at some
point. So, for some reason, the Python
devs decided that slice should not be
hashable, and then they decided it
should be hashable, and now it's like
there's a breaking change from 311 to
312.
Okay. And
then
lib.utils. This is API stuff that we've
We'll just uh Neptune this
thing and we will see what this does out
of the
box. See what this does out of the box
in a few
minutes.
Meanwhile, maze looks like it
crashed. Yeah, these look like they
might have both
Interesting. Well, let's let's get
this Yeah, it's going to be a lot of
context switching today. Let's get this
to run.
And then we'll have this window
launched. So, here's our run that we
have for the thing we just
launched. And let's go check. Let's go
check to see if either of these crashed.
This looks totally fine,
right? Yep. So, breakout is still
going. And then
crash. Error while computing log
prop at site Y.
What on earth is this?
Pyro. It isn't
pyro. Okay. So then the only thing
that's left here is it seems like it is
possible for
um uh the
actual sweep itself to still error out.
that. Where do we think we could get NS
in here?
The score is not something that can be
nanable because we don't use the loss
for the Four.
So somehow
here uh something is not
getting propagated correctly.
Oh, wait. Log C minus log C
min. This could
zero. Well, then we're just training
everything to map to zero, right?
6 is
zero. I don't think that it's possible
that you get um nans in the training
data, but I mean I guess
oops I forgot I had multiple
workspaces. What is this going to tell
us here?
So GPUs train is where this
breaks
428 it breaks on this GP cost and cost
opt
optimizer. So, it's just uh this data
that's set from here.
And is this a um is this a CUDA
error or can I catch
this? I actually think we can catch this
because that's not a CUDA error, right?
That's like a validation
So, we redo this
sweep. And now we should hopefully get a
break point the next time it
crashes because I think we got all of
the nan bugs out of the main
transcript. There's like one last
potential
instability uh in the inputs to
pyro and then hopefully we should have
stable
sweeps. Go check on this
experiment. Okay. So, yeah, this is
unfortunately this is on par with the
previous
uh not so great train
runs where they get stuck at 0.5.
Pyro is uh it's the Gaussian process
optimizer that we're using. It's like
um it's just like a torch extension
library that has Gaussian processes and
stuff in it. So we will unfortunately
have to add that as a depth unless we
want to implement our own Gaussian
processes which are really annoying to
implement.
Upper lib
environments meta
meta and this is the config we
used. Let's just open it.
Another good
question was when I did this
experiment, which actually I linked this
to Aaron yesterday, so I can go find
that
link. I did go link this to Aaron.
21st 3
E06. It was this commit here.
hypers. We can double check these real
quick, but I'm pretty sure these are the
same. Yep. So,
like these are all the same, right?
Okay. The other thing I wasn't sure
about with this that I wanted to go
double check
on is did we have the end file committed
at this point?
We did have the Nap file committed, but
I can actually verify here
uh that this is exactly what we trained
on with all these cool downs just as
they were
I wonder if it's possible that something
changed in their config
format. You think something could have
changed in their config format such that
like now uh this is like no longer valid
or
something? This is a totally different
curve,
right? I want to check
that. That could be the case.
memory. Just loading the GPU quite a
bit.
buffer cuz this gets passed. This gets
passed in.
at the
data. Nothing there.
objects. Yeah. So, this just tells you
everything that's in the end, which is
going to be a ton of stuff,
right? Oh, yeah. This is a massive
amount of stuff.
wrapper
attribute. Where's the config get uh
applied in here? I think I got to just
start reading
their their end code, right?
underscore? Does have an underscorem
config and it is the one that I
Wait.
Self.config equals
get new end
config.
Wait, this gets
passed and then it makes a template of
this.
Okay. And then it resolves this
config. Now this is the config that we
All these are red
ores. These ones
changed. Like it would have to be the
end, right? Because
It's got to be the
end. Let me see. So, I like I remember
it wasn't working. We got curves that
looked like
this and then I pasted
in where is
it? Okay. So, I pasted in these new
params.
these. Okay. So I pasted in these new
params which was the new learning rate,
gamma, lambda, all that. And then we had
it working very
well. I just pasted these in from like a
quick sweep. I remember
m* 16, right? That was the idea. 16
workers
batch size 64.
Yeah, this is a uh double buffered
setup with a bunch of
workers. Same
params. Didn't mess with the end config
in any weird way.
trying to think if there's like is it
possible I did
see. Reset enth.
So they have this reset
m.reset. I should be fine just calling
reset here then.
seed. We could double check. We should
double check. We're getting real
data. Pretty darn sure we did this
right.
Always possible I messed up
though. So we go
here and we do mode
Okay. I mean, like, we see that there's
data in here, right? Like not a ton of
stuff, but like there is we've seen a
couple channels already that had stuff
in
them. Yeah. So, I mean, there's data
And then we have our
encoder network is a small
fine. And this is what we used
importantly as well.
I wonder if I messed up the action
decoding for
it. I tried on old puffer li though too,
didn't
I? Pretty darn sure I tried on old
puffer
li. Worth
checking. Do I have any other like
multi-discrete
M's? Hang on. Actually, I do. Let me
just test if I can learn one of those
real quick. We should have like the
sanity
make we had
multi-discrete. I know we have a
multi-discreet in here.
Uh, I'm trying to figure out how do I
reconnect
these real quick
M. Oh, let's just
make faces.
seed.
Holy. Well, this was what we wanted.
bugged. Okay, so there is something
wrong I think with spaces. I don't know
whether it's the same bug or
not, but uh it's worth us looking
oops into this decoder.
multi-discretet. You know, it looks like
I could have messed this up at all. like
quite a bit
and just check how I did this in like
earlier
versions. I think
um this could definitely be it. I could
have just messed up multi-discrete
sampling.
That's the only other thing I could
think of that I touched that would like
specifically mess up meta and not
anything
else. I thought I was being pretty
careful with it, but maybe not.
So,
interestingly, yeah, but this is the dev
branch. We need to go back
farther to like
before I did
this, like to here
Can I just like copy this whole
function?
Actually, I should be able
to. I don't know if I messed with
anything else that would matter in
here. Entropy.
gets called unnormalized
budgets budgets.
Okay, I think I can actually
not mess with this so much and just
do
We'll see if this produces anything
different.
26 to
262 97. Right.
there. Yes. This was the original
one. Now this is the new one.
So this
was we can see the two different we can
see this one lines up with this one. So
even if we go back to the
earlier the earlier action sampling it
does not seem to make a difference.
Did I mess with any of the other
functions in
here?
Nope, that is
correct. This is identical.
And I do not
believe I did anything
else. Evidently, I did not just break
sampling.
then? I know I didn't just break
this. Thank
I've already also to be clear I've
tested this exact branch as well. I'm
not just like
guessing. Adding the resets here. Added
max
steps. These are all the changes I
remember and these are all up to date.
Um, hang on. We have somebody here with
delivery that I don't know who this is.
Apparently, we have an entire semi worth
of lights uh that our electric guys
ordered for a different job to our
address.
weird. What are we going to do about
this freaking this run?
This isn't a case where I just like did
something and I don't remember what I
did. Like I know exactly what I
did. I think I'm doing the same thing
and it's not
replicating. In fact, it's not just I
think I know what I did, right? I have
the get
commits. I have the diff to the commit.
Exactly. The heck could have possibly
changed? And all the other M's work
great as
well. Jiggle the hyperparameters around
a little bit, but
like,
right, I could also rerun a hyperparam
sweep on this. That's a thing I could
do.
I mean realistically right this is
supposed to
fix this is supposed to do well
within okay 1 E8 so 100 million steps
you should be able to see a very
substantial
sweep. I'm not confident that's going to
get us
anywhere, but I can at least try that.
It's weird because we got the we got
this curve with these
model. No other
diffs unless Hang on. Wait a second.
Does this record This does record the
entire diff,
on. I think it is just a diff to the
train
screenshot. It should just It is just a
diff to this one
file. Okay. Wait. that that changes
things. Yeah. And you can see the diff
here just it's on the config file
Let's do some like 100 milish runs,
right? Just let's play with some
if this does anything.
I'm just gonna I don't want to spend all
day doing this, but you know, it's worth
playing with this a little bit just to
make sure I didn't screw something
up because I just realized if it's not
recording the full
diff and uh there could be different
there could be differences.
This
here to
there. In the
meantime, double check on some runs.
up for grid is still going just
one. Okay. So, there's like some rare
instability in pyro, but other than
that, we've kind of gotten our sweep
stable as well, but we are in a decent
spot. I would say
overall in a decent spot.
We can see we actually
have quite comprehensive sweep on
breakout
here. Uh not seeing a bunch of good runs
though. We probably are going to want to
mess with our sweep setup if this is all
we're getting out of
it. Open
dashboard sweep
progress. Yeah, not great on the sweeps.
So, we definitely screwed something up
with our sweeps.
It is possible. It's just like the
normalization change I
made. So, this is not doing great. But
if it's not sweeping breakout well, then
we don't expect it to do particularly
well.
our breakout sweep right.
This is breakout.
changes it having the max score in place
and if so then we can work off of
Maybe we can track some other stats from
this and we can get like a hint from
um from some of these stats,
eh? Cuz like this should have logged a
whole bunch of
Yes. No, we didn't log SPS or
anything. How is there so many metrics
here?
stat. Okay. So, they don't like this
attack
nearest. It doesn't learn this quickly
at all.
Get
output. Just learn super
quickly. Get output.
Interestingly, we learn to move around a
whole bunch.
But we just have like this very
slow. I mean, even from
like you can tell these apart like 20
million steps
in right here. This
is battery
gained. This should be learnable
immediately as well.
It gets rewarded for
Okay. It's funny because this it's not
getting rewarded for
this. So these this agent just says
screw that and this agent's like you
know doing its own
thing. Would it make
sense? Hang
on
two. It's not at 0.2. It's at like 0.4.
But like
still these are probably rare. It's kind
of treating these like any other
resource,
or and then this heart here. It's also
not again like 50 mil steps. You can
tell it
apart for less.
Okay. So, this
is it's
treating it seems like it's not getting
the rewards is what it really seems like
to me.
ore. Ah, okay. Hang
on. So,
here or
red.get. This is like not terribly far
off,
right? It's getting the ore
here. It's not learning to do anything
with
them. Yeah. It hasn't learned to like
put
them
anywhere. But I mean, this would imply
that it is getting the reward,
right? You think I changed the
conversion time to zero?
quick. And we already have one
conversion
tick on
everything. And that was like that's the
way it just was.
You know, we do actually know one other
thing which is that I did I committed
this
file. I actually did commit this
file with uh that PR that I marked.
like it was actually quite well
uh that this was this was the state this
file was in.
So actually I am quite confident then
that I didn't just mess with the end
config. In which case I can't think of
really anything better to do than just
run a sweep,
Of course, our current sweep stuff is
messed
healing that guy? Hey,
Tyler. Yeah, I know. It's all right. He
uh he's mostly just a poster. He's like
I don't know maybe half the engineer
that he is a poster. And thanks for the
free exposure. I
I know. I thought that was pretty funny.
It's
like you can poke a little bit of fun at
Google, right?
I mean, they were like, "Yeah,
artificial uh puffer intelligence and
stuff in the comments." All
right, grab some
second. It's also pretty funny that I've
been in RL longer than this.
So, nice try, buddy.
try. Yeah, Tyler. The thing I'm trying
to figure out right at the moment, there
are two things. One is I'm just fixing
hyper pram sweeps and like fixing some
stability issues in the latest build
that I'm pretty confident we'll be able
to get to work.
The thing that's really weird at the
moment
though, I can't get We are setting soda
on every single M pretty much out of the
box except this one M that we set soda
on like three weeks ago. We can't
reproduce at
all. And it's a pretty important
one. I have no idea why this one end is
just not working the way it was expected
to.
It's meta. It's a third party M that's
built with the Puffer APIs.
Um, do I really trust this
gamma? I'm going to just do something
dumb for the hell of
it. One random thing just to check.
And then after that, I'll just ignore
this. I'll go back
to the hyperparam sweep stuff or general
cleanup. Then when the hyperp stuff
works correctly,
uh then we will just rerun on this and
see. And if that doesn't work, it must
have been an M change because
like it's just not a thing that happens
in Puffer, right? We don't lose
experiments.
I mean, it's like pretty
instant that this thing learns. And it
should be
working. Yeah. And then none of these
are applicable here.
Oh, I guess there is the April. If we go
here, there are a bunch of
changes. This one
So, this actually is like pretty close
to this one as well. It's suspicious
that I can't find anything that's
like everything kind of matches this.
Nothing like gets even 6 or
anything. It's kind of weird. It's like
it everything is screaming that this is
an Mside change.
Is this trajectory
related? What is
um 26
[Music]
over
128 128 horizon
length be
fine.
Wait, that's not that many.
That's not that many
M's. Honestly, don't know what I'm
looking at, but keep it
up. Thanks. I This is currently
debugging like a fiddly some fiddly RL
experiments. Um, pretty much like we set
a whole bunch of really good results a
couple of weeks ago and then I left for
a week and I came back and we reproduced
all the results perfectly except for
one. I'm trying to figure out what
happened to this like one experiment.
Um, and usually I'm pretty good at like
tracking or tracking our changes, making
sure we don't lose stuff. So, it's a
really weird a really weird case.
I don't even know why I'm spending so
much time thinking about this when it's
like I know I didn't modify the
environment file,
right? I know I ran
experiments on the same thing.
with the exact same
lib. Those two things don't make sense
together, right?
Maybe I shouldn't be
too suspicious of this flat curve
either. I do seem to remember it being
very difficult to get it to go above 0.5
until I set the new hyperparams.
Would totally make sense though if I
change something
else at the same
time. Pretty well remember what I did
though that day and I didn't do anything
else.
At least I didn't do anything else in
the end
configuration. Possible I had like some
local changes to
Metagrid. Had some like local changes to
the environment
file. The only thing I remember doing
there though was
um resetting the ends. Making sure I
reset the ends. Doing that correctly now
as well.
bizarre. I also don't know how it is
that my
uh breakout sweep suddenly doesn't work.
right? That's definitely got to be a
bug. Okay, I'm going to let this do the
do its thing. I'm going to grab a drink
and then we'll just we'll ignore this
for now and we'll just fix sweeps
because maybe in fixing sweeps we just
rerun the sweep and we get RAMs that
work. You see it literally starts off
wrong. You see
that? Literally the first point starts
off
wrong. Doesn't that imply it has to be
end
Unless it's just like it learned so much
in the first
update, but no, right? Because you
collect all the
data. No, this is literally has to be
end config.
Unless it could just take a few updates,
I guess. You
know, I already reran the I already
reran the commit is the thing. Hey,
Plasma. I'm doing okay. I'm still just
like trying to reproduce this
experiment, which is weird.
I was so careful to not change the
environment, but
like this gap here, it like it almost
has to
be environment changed if it's like
literally the first point recorded. I
mean, technically this is already 14
million steps
still. H. Okay, here's what we're going
to do. This is going to drive me crazy
if I just spend all day doing this. And
uh unlikely we're going to get anywhere
with just me staring at it.
Um and grab a drink, do a set or two
real
quick, clear my head,
and then we will see if I can fix the
hyper pram sweep stuff that I actually
have some idea of what I might have
broken that I know should work very
well. And I know like I have a better
idea of what can be uh of what stuff I
changed there and what like we can fix.
We fix hyperparam sweeps. Um we can at
least rerun all the other experiments
except this end. Come back to this and
we'll go from there. Be right back.
pink and green as a result. Yeah, the
green is the uh the pink is the original
one and then we can't get anywhere close
to it. It's very
weird. It's very very weird.
report.
Interesting. Oh, cuz it's
311 there.
So, we should be
getting 10 observations back here.
These
hypers look totally wrong.
Okay. So, these are the
correct these are the correct ones.
Okay, we do have total time steps here.
So this is 1.5 million steps. So this is
like a very
early first point it looks
like. Score is zero.
cost is like nothing, right? So, we just
do or cost. We'll do like this.
Continue. Now, the next
one is at 11
million, which is 17 score and 7 seconds
into
training. 20 mil
Okay. So, we can see that we're actually
observing
correctly the various different
um
points. Now, this should be the last
point here. And this is on
eval. This total time step should be
wrong. Yeah, because this is only for
eval. So, we'll fix this real
Let's
see. So,
right? That will get us to 80 mil or
whatever. That's not the bug, though.
That's not the thing that's breaking
everything. Tell you that for sure.
again. So this will run.
And uh we will see whether we observe
the correct step.
observations. So this is going to give
us a random suggestion.
The goal is just going to be to see how
all the data is getting
normalized and uh why the predictions
don't make any sense cuz like looking at
this graph right from over where is
it? But like you get a couple of
reasonable random suggestions and then
it just doesn't do
anything. Like for some reason it's
pushing cost all the way to the bottom
or whatever.
parameters. Expect these to be
reasonable.
Here's our
Y. Does it look good? Right.
Min score is
zero. That's
fine. Max score.
Whoa.
What? Well, this is completely
wrong right here. This is
wrong. I don't know why I would do this
abs thing like
this. It should
be
this. Okay.
score. That could totally be it right
there if I'm not setting max scores.
Right.
though. Okay. So, like this is half
offish, right? But it's bad. It's like
not
costs. Apparently, that didn't work, but
whatever.
We will try again with the our new found
fixes. This
observations. Now we have reasonable log
cost observations, right?
cost goes into log
space. I actually don't know why we put
cost in log space to be fair,
right? We've played with it a few
different
ways. Well, we'll leave this as is for
now.
reasonable. Okay, here's your norm. 0 to
one. Quite clean.
them. Pretty much all of them, right?
Yeah, literally all of them. It should
be if we have a good initial
curve. Then we sample some
suggestions. suggestions, shape, whole
bunch of suggestions,
right?
We we score
Then we have GPY
norm log C
norm
GPY. What do we do? It's times max score
minus min
score. You actually don't need this uh
this abs at
all. The worst case is zero
here.
Right. I don't think you need this abs.
zero. So now they're getting multiplied
by max minus
min and then add to min.
Yeah. Then we have log
c it's x.
You have to see get a min and a
max.
See?
Okay. And you have your parto
y parto indices.
Okay, got your
PTO. Was it log C
norm? Uh, I don't think this
C. Wait, do we still use this like C
right thing?
used. Yeah. So, let's not confuse
ourselves
here because none of these get used
anymore, right?
Now, this doesn't get
used. This does get used.
here? This is not what I
remember, but maybe I'm reading my own
stuff wrong. Hang on.
So,
target equals
GPC
norm. Oh, look. This this just gets
deleted here. You see
this? Yeah. This all just goes away.
It's right here. Yeah. This is what I
remember. So, it's just
1.25 times a
random. It's multiplied by a
weight. This GPY
norm, you got to make sure GPY norm is
right. Is right here.
times the
argmax. Let's commit this and then see
if this does anything different.
uh, let's see how this changes
it. So, we had
Okay, this actually this breakout sweep
was starting to do kind of
something. Let's see now with the fixes
if we actually get something reasonable
out of
it. Let me read that in a second.
Tyler, let me at least get this run
started so we can have this
going. Check your thing.
Romy. Okay. So, yeah, let me let me help
you with
that. The Romy show drone
ideas for our natural
I'm trying to think if you actually
really need a
it. And the no military is always a fun
thing.
What kind of pro? Well, all of them
honestly in like drones like the whole
RL is super human at drone piloting for
the first part. Uh if you get it right,
it's also super human at
coordination. the
like so like some communication stuff
would
be useful in like a variety of
applications. The really like heavily
like swarm-based stuff is probably
military stuff. Um but I mean the tech
goes way farther than that. Like if you
want to get into something that is like
defense but not military for instance,
right? Um, you can purely have these
things for like surveying an existing
premise and like covering an
area. That's like security, even private
security
there. That's like a pretty reasonable
thing. I think generally you want to
have these things be able to
like you want to have these things be
able to make reasonable decisions based
off of either shared information or like
local or responsive to one another
depending
um I guess like the spread out and do X
is a good application. So
like there is probably stuff in
agriculture with that to be fair.
Although I don't know if it's effective
like powering them and having like all
that stuff versus just like having
something on the
ground. Let me think of like what would
get somebody excited that's not military
drone stuff.
quick. Well, I mean, is she interested
in science generally because it's like
an excellent
uh it's an excellent problem for
studying like
decentralized uh like decentralized
aggregate behavior and the like,
right? I mean, it's like the problem
that you would go to in the real world
for like relatively efficient,
relatively doable coordinated behavior.
I mean that's like fundamental to our
understanding
of everything from ants to how companies
are run,
right? So in a sense it's just like it's
a very good science problem in some
sense, right? That also will get enough
people in industry interested that it's
like actually viable to scale research
on it. And yeah, obviously there's like
some stuff that's military there.
There's stuff that's like security
adjacent, but I mean broader than that,
like the same tech goes on everything,
right? So like the things that you came
up with are possibly reasonable. Um even
if you don't apply the exact same stuff
to a drone form factor, you can apply
the same algorithm to like a ground unit
for removing weeds if you wanted to do
that. Maybe that's more reasonable. Like
the algorithm side is going to be very
very similar. It's just that if you're
trying to pick a problem to get a large
number of people interested, um, drones
are just a very flashy one that's very
good at that. And technically, it's very
similar to many other things that you
could look
at. That's kind of the way I would look
at it, right? Because I do a lot of
general RL tech and then every so often
I look for problems where it's like,
okay, this is an area where a lot of
people will get excited if we kind of
demonstrated our tech on this. There
probably a lot of downstream
applications. There always going to be
some that are military and some that
aren't, right?
But I think that this is just generally
an area where uh if you can get RL
working on it very well, you will get a
lot of people excited. You'll power a
lot of like fundamental advancements in
RL and in our understanding of aggregate
intelligence in general or collective
intelligence in general. And you'll push
a lot of things quite far
forward. And it's actually a problem
where I think it's like relatively
reasonable to do that because like it's
the air. They have to not collide with
each other and that's about it.
So you'll probably just even if you
don't like you will probably get some
really fascinating aerial displays out
of it, right? You'll probably get some
really fascinating aerial
displays. Like if you can just control a
whole bunch of them and say, "Hey, all
of you go do this. All of you go do
that." And do it like in a way that
makes sense without crashing into each
other and stuff like that will already
be and there's really not much like
that. They show her where like M agent
for instance like it's on David Ha's
website. So like M agent or
this? If you look at even just like
basic stuff like
this, right? Imagine doing this in like
actual 3D with drones or like even like
voids.
right there. Like all these flocking
type sims and
things. This is all these are all like
models of coordinated
right. Have we run any
experiments in the
meantime or did they
Welcome YouTube folks.
We're currently working on getting our
hyperprem stuff uh sweeps back working
so we can run some large scale
uh like few hundred order few hundred
run hyperp sweeps over all our new
environments and see how well our our
new algorithm can
do on all of the environments because
like right now we're pretty much solving
everything out of the box uh without
even having retune stuff. So, I imagine
that we can do quite a bit better even
than we're doing
now, which should set us up
for a a very solid
release. I'm particularly interested to
see like neural MMO is kind of an
expensive M, so we don't retune hyper
prams all that often. And like this is
kind of just what we've gotten out
of mostly scaling up the network a
little bit, but also just little tweaks
I've made here and there to it. Um, so
I'm interested to see with a really
optimized hypers how well we can do this
thing. This is an old
website. Yeah, I mean there are a bunch
of implementations of it. Um, uh, Plasma
in the Discord is actually doing a voids
environment for Puffer right now.
Uh we don't have voids on this one, but
yeah, he showed us uh he we've got like
a little interesting voids type sim that
he's been working on for Popper. Have
that merged in soon
hopefully. And Spencer is also
interested in drones. Well, there are a
lot of people interested in the
Oh, one of the uh pieces of gym
equipment I'm waiting for shipped. The
one I'm really looking forward
But probably uh sometime in the next few
days I will have to get up and go take
freight
delivery. All right, this is now
running. We will see whether this is
stable or not.
Um, so the first five
runs
are well the first run is like going to
always be good and then the next few are
randomly sampled and then after that the
algorithm takes
over. So now the algorithm is suggesting
stuff that's like 20 mil. I don't know
why it's suggesting such short runs.
That will be the next thing uh for us to
look at.
Okay. Yeah. So, it's doing something. It
should not be doing this where it's like
pushing
uh the cost all the way to the bottom.
I'm going to give it a few more runs to
see if it keeps doing this. And then I'm
going to what we'll do is we'll like
we'll boot up an individual run and
we'll see if we can figure out why. In
fact, why don't we just do that on our
local while it's doing
that. I like this is something that I
actually I worked very hard to make sure
that this algorithm doesn't do. So, this
must just be like some weird bug in
something I did
recently. A lot of these algorithms,
they'll kind of just give up and they'll
be like, I can't figure out how to make
the long experiments work anymore, so
I'll just run cheap
experiments. That's quite silly,
actually. I know that this divide
parameter is not used. We don't have to
worry about
that. Oh, and here actually this LF
false. Oh, I committed this. So,
actually then the first few runs were
fine,
right? The first few runs were fine and
then it started doing this.
H, we'll start uh we'll start from here
and we'll see what this uh what this
does. Yeah. You see all these runs being
here? Yeah, it's because they're all
down here in total time steps except
this
one. I wonder if this is like something
to do with log
cost. This could just be something weird
with the way I've defined log cost,
right?
zero. Oh, you know, that's totally what
it is,
right? I see. So, I think it's
because this is a little silly. So
because cost starts like very close to
zero
um and it's going on a log scale, it's
actually going to put a decent chunk of
our runs
uh very low
cost and we literally like it can it
can't set fewer than 20 million time
steps. That's the minimum we allow.
Yeah. So like generally if you think
about that then if I did if I try to do
a run that was like between a billion
and 1.5 billion steps it's always going
to do a billion because on a log scale
it's going to get some early
checkpoints and then it's going to try
to sample in the space of cost 0 to 1.5
billion in a log
scale. Most of the time you're going to
be uh below a billion. So it rounds up
to a
billion. This is why when I like I look
at this
stuck. Well, I know what now I know what
the problem is. I don't even need to
look at this. I just need to think of
how I want to solve it.
And this specifically comes from the
fact that I'm adding traces like full uh
full
traces of the
curves. I guess one thing we could do
is
we we only
need. We can just change the way our
sampling works, right?
But let's say we don't log any partial
points. We don't log any points that
are below the minimum number of time
steps that we could run a full
experiment
for. That would be a start.
start, I think. Let's just do that for
now and then let's see what happens,
right?
We can just do it as like a quick hack
for now as well. Make sure it works and
then we can like figure out how we want
to really do it.
Like here this this down sample
here
for you. You help with one topic. I'm
stuck. Depends what it
is. Is anything adjacent to any of this
stuff? Then
sure. Um, global
step greater than
equal. Let me figure out what the
parameter is called.
There's a
config ars.
regression. I can point you to better
resources depending on what you're where
you're trying to learn stuff from.
I imagine you're like studying stuff
like where are you currently studying
that from?
Okay, that'll run. We'll see if that
does anything.
That's literally logistic regression
right
there. Like that's
it. Now obviously you got to write your
own backwards and stuff, but
like it's just a linear layer in a
sigmoid.
between linear and logistic regression.
It's the sigmoid.
Well, I guess it depends on regression
and
classification. If you're regressing one
variable as a as a sample, it's
literally all right. And then you do
like the
loss. It's like
forward
rag like
boss something like this. Y is your like
your output
variable and then it's for logistic
regression you literally just add in the
sigmoid. So you can only learn linear
decision boundaries. Your data has to be
linearly separable for linear regression
to work. Logistic regression gives you
one nonlinear activation to play with.
can learn nonlinear
all. Now, look, I mean, I'm I'm
minimizing a little bit here cuz like I
remember spending several hundred hours
when I was 16 being very very confused
by like fundamental ML stuff as well.
And I still would be confused if I went
and go look at like pure math after not
having looked at it for like the last
couple years or whatever. But
conceptually these things are quite
simple. And then
um I mean when you go implement your own
autograd and stuff things are like
annoying because you have to make sure
you get everything right and like there
are million tricks in modern uh ML that
make things just work the way that you
would expect them to. If you don't if
you implement stuff yourself without
those tricks, it just won't work
anywhere near as well and you'll be
confused as to why. But conceptually
these things are quite simple.
meanwhile. It is still pushing this all
the way down to the
bottom. Still
doing ridiculously short runs.
lost. Oh, you know what it is. I'm dumb.
Okay, I'm dumb. I know what I did wrong.
And I know why this did like
um Yeah, I know exactly what I
before. Target
minus. Oh, no. Wait. Isn't this fine?
This is fine, right? Because it's
point minus GP log C
norm. Wait, this should be in log space
then,
right? And this is running a longer
experiment right
So, um, to give you a bit of an idea of
what we're looking at here,
um, this is our new hyperpar tuning
algorithm. I've been sitting on this
result for several months. It's a very,
very good hyperparam tuning algorithm,
but we made a few changes recently and
we kind of broke a few things. Um, so
I'm trying to get it back to its old
level of PF for the upcoming release. uh
and currently what's happening is that
uh the way the algorithm works is it
picks a length of experiment
uh and then it tries to select and it
tries to guess an experiment that it
thinks it'll do well that'll take about
that long. What it does is it runs a
whole bunch of experiments of different
lengths. It builds up predictive models
of how long an experiment is going to
take and how well it thinks it's going
to do and then tries to pick the best
experiments of all different lengths.
The idea here is that you know you run
short experiments, you run long
experiments, you actually start off
running shorter experiments and then
gradually start running longer ones as
you be get more confident. Uh it's a
very simple algorithm. It's very robust.
It doesn't have a lot of the problems
that a lot of the other algorithms had.
But one of those uh right now is that
it's running a lot of really really
short experiments. And I think the
reason for this is just that I messed
up. And uh instead of trying to tell it
to pick an experiment from uh that takes
between the length of the shortest
experiment it's ever run and the length
of the longest experiment, it instead
just tries to like pick an experiment of
any length up to the longest. So like
it's going to pick a lot of experiments
that are below the minimum length which
then just get capped off to the minimum
length. And uh yeah, that's what I think
is happening.
It's still running a bunch of really
short experiments though, even though I
I should have had that fixed based on
this. How's a random forest model make
predictions? No idea. Those are so old.
I literally like I've never used a
random forest.
I mean all my work is deep neural nets,
right? Except for I guess technically
this um this hyperparameter tuning
algorithm uses Gaussian processes.
That's about it.
All right. So, the problem is still
definitely here,
right? We got one reasonably length like
one reasonable length to run and the
rest of them are they went all the way
to the top and then all the way to the
bottom. So, something's screwy here.
Why do deep neural networks tend to
perform better than shallow ones? I mean
they can
well the real answer is
um like what is it uh divine serendipity
or whatever like we don't know but uh
approximately correct answer handwavy
answer is deeper neural nets you have
more nonlinearities in the middle uh
they also tend to be larger and they can
represent more classes of functions
uh so that they can represent more data.
Like if you have a complex function, you
have a one layer neural net of like a
specific capacity, it might not just be
able to represent the decision boundary
that you want. It's a regression class.
might not be able to represent that
problem like you're training a thing to
approximate another thing, right? If
first thing is very simple and then
second thing is very complicated, simple
thing can't represent complicated thing
very well.
So it is this one is a longer experiment
here I can
see. So it is running some longer
experiments but
like it's
screwy. It's like screwy what it's
doing. Let me figure out what this is.
What's happening here? What a break
point like right
here. Do like
this. Hey, free to work on GPU drive
stuff. Sure, Spencer. Uh, give
me give me like two minutes to go run
use the restroom and then we will uh
I'll jump on a call or whatever for
that and do a set.
Ara, is this asking you stuff or you
giving me
like introductory ML quiz? You know, I
haven't used any of these algorithms in
like almost a decade,
right? It's a clustering algorithm. It's
an unsupervised learning algorithm. You
want to partition data into K groups
where the things in each group are
similar to each
other. I don't remember the distance
metric that is used in the algorithm
because I haven't used it in a
Spencer probably already in the Discord.
Nope.
Yep. How's it going, man? Hey, going
well. Let me uh mute you on the stream.
Hold up. Uhhuh. I've been
debugging all sorts of crazy things.
Oh, yeah.
We're making progress. Slow though.
Uh, so I made a PR by just pulling in
the latest dev stuff into my GPU drive
branch. Um, let me go deal with that.
Hang on. Oops.
I will note up front it does
not compile to to train from the latest
stuff in dev.
I'm not certain if you would have wanted
me to just put that into the PR and then
you'd handle it in dev or if you want to
pull my or pull my existing branch from
my repo.
Uh what why doesn't it compile?
Uh you have some new agents per batch
thing in buffer. Just we'll just pull
that and fix
And then it looks like from the files I
dropped in there when I pulled dev, it
looks like you have a new build
simple.sh as
well.
Build simple. I don't know what the heck
that
is. Okay. So, a lot of file
changes. You PR this to dev. Okay.
Well, you haven't seen the new release
branch stuff, which is way crazier even.
Yeah. I mean, I don't know what's all in
between various things. A lot. A lot.
So, I can start I can pull some things
out of here. Well, I love So, let me see
what So, what
is So, I see that there is some reward
tuning.
This was a little bit of like kind of
like a dirty pull from just like me just
syncing from dev and then merging stuff.
Okay. And then we have this demo file.
Most of what's changed is
in theh
file which has more render stuff I
worked on. Uhhuh. Um that that GPU drive
test file can probably be dropped out. I
guess that just got tossed in there from
my branch. It's a dev branch. Doesn't
freaking matter. So, I mean, those files
can just be deleted in the future. It's
no big deal.
There's a diff here. There's a 300 some
odd line edition here.
Yeah, that's um my changes to render
in.h means new drive. And then also
there's a there's some changes I had to
make to match how the NYU project
worked. Okay, that's good.
The means trick right there was just
something so that the the camera always
is on
origin. Also, did you I just ran one
random thing. Did you make a full set of
animations for um power climb or is
there like one missing where it just
like snaps?
Um the one that it would be missing
is jumping off a block.
I see. Everything else there's something
where there's one where it's like it
looks really smooth and then it just
snaps.
Um I'll have to you you'll have to show
me which one that is.
Because some of them it's about playing
with like the timing of when the
animation ends versus
For sure. If you're wrapping a block, it
snaps because there's not really a good
way to animate like
going around the cube.
I'll have to fix the config for this.
Um, but yeah, there's a couple weird
things. Anyways,
um, GPU drive doesn't have any animation
stuff. This is all just like drawings
and
camera and c uh this one also has the
three the third person camera uh
view. Um that is me turning a curb into
a 3D rectangle.
Wait.
3D raised by curb
height. Wait, is this now you're drawing
triangles for the curb?
Yeah.
What is this actually like a triangle
strip or what is this? It makes it so
that as you're wrapping a corner and the
curb curves, it looks like a like a
round corner.
All right, we'll look at what this is.
Cool. I I guess I will see what it looks
like. Done a whole bunch of stuff on
this. Oh, you added a car.
Yeah.
Yay. Sure. I'm going to have complaints
about the car and have to get a cool car
made.
Yeah. I mean, I I just picked a car from
online and then went inside of Blender
to go change the color of it to have
multiple different colored cars.
Uh, you committed TF record files.
Are these levels? What are these? Uh,
those look to be
I can toss those out. Are they sample
levels or like what are they? I think
they're from the examples of the like
pre-process stuff when I first was doing
it. It seems like my commit also just
dropped. It's not bad to have an example
level by the way. Um then those are
example levels. Cool. Whatever. We're
fine. I don't And I don't know what
build simple is. I don't know what this
is.
It looks like when I did my merge, it
just like pulled stuff in. Yeah,
whatever.
thing. All right. So here we have your
GPU
drive build
Uh you're on uh test performance. Go to
this. Go to the C file and
demo.
Oh, does look
cool. Is these are these are 3D curves?
Yep. You actually made Okay. The only
feedback I have you for there is that
there is a draw triangle strip function.
instead of having to draw individual
triangles. But yeah, that is awesome.
Cool. Uh and like because you have that,
it's actually probably not that hard now
to make potentially more elevated things
and put the cars in a maze. H
Yeah. I mean, you could do whatever you
want at this point in terms of drawing
levels.
Yeah. And if only they drove around.
Yeah. If you switch to move expert and
step, you can see what the policy is
supposed to be
doing in theh file.
Okay, I can do that. What is the thing
we want to debug? This thing not train
well or what? Yes, that would be
priority number one. Okay, let's let's
do that. So, but step one is first
getting it to work with the new dev
stuff that's in there cuz Okay, I was
working on a fairly old
dev. It compiles, but it does not rain.
I guess
um I think it's just missing a parameter
because if you put it on
uh native on on without multipprocessing
it just runs into a bug in clean buffer
RL right
just stop. Oh, someone from your someone
from your chat says that uh your audio
is kind of low.
[Music]
Joseph's audio is way low
comparatively. Does that mean that
you're too Say something? Hello. Yeah.
Okay. Your mic is just super
high. All
right. Say something again. What's up?
Mic down a little bit more. All right.
Let me know if this is good. I had to
just mix the thing.
Dec agents
per doesn't exist in native M2, but we
can
multiprocess. I think multipprocessing
is a little weird on this as well, but
we can look at that later at one point.
Okay, we have it as default now for
everything pretty much. Ah, okay. I
think I've noticed some differences on
multipprocessing versus native.
Your mic super high. All right, we'll
try this.
Am I still exploding eardrums?
Um I it should be pretty close to mine
now at this point. I just for me to mix.
No
worries.
Uh yeah. So, this is this is the fun
thing with uh having to get the batches
all correct, right?
Yeah. Yeah. So, you want you want to
have like a multiple of the number of
cars or whatever the number of agents.
So, how many agents is this? Do we know
up front
um for this round?
No, it's an awkward number. Let me do a
Let me It looks like 1847 or
But we do
36. Is that the total number?
So, one thing to take a note of is I did
something funky in my Sython.
Before you do some of this, I multiplied
times eight already inside the Sython.
What do you multiply by eight? The
number of agents. Why?
Um, it was an experiment because at the
time I was only doing something I was
only just kind of getting 75 levels to
go and when you only had 75 levels, it
only gave you like, you know, a few
hundred agents. So, I wanted to get more
parallelization going on those seven on
this on the when working with 75 maps.
So, I cloned that those agents into more
M's.
Okay. All I want to do here for
reference is I just want to figure out
how many cards you have and set the
batch size to be like 64 times that and
the mini batch size to be like eight
times that. That's all I really want to
do.
Okay. So, like how many cars do we have?
Then you're going to be looking
582 cars. That's it. Across 75 maps.
Yeah. All
right. That's how that's how many active
agent cars there should
be. You have a pretty small batch size,
but whatever.
Yeah. I mean, that's why I I decided to
do like the the multiply by eight thing
inside of the Sython. So if you want to
reverse that out, what but the
multi if you have 8x the number of cars
being used for
obs, don't I? Yeah. So that that's what
I was I thought you wanted the original
number. I mean 4656. Okay. So it's it is
32. Not it is
226. Your batch size is
226. And what are you doing with those
extra cars?
I was just trying to get some more M's
going. What do you mean more?
Okay, so right now the num m's parameter
is directly correlates to the map index
0 through 74. Did you just make eight
copies of each map? Yes. Oh yeah, that's
if you said that it immediately. Yeah,
that's totally fine. Whatever.
Okay. Yeah, that's I Okay,
cool. So, where is this
thing? 5 30 this divide by what is it? 8
28,000. These things take a while to
load.
Is it
stuck?
It looks that way.
Normally when there's something like
that going on, it's related to Neptune
or Wani.
I didn't think I ran it with Neptune,
did I?
No, I don't know if you did, but
normally that's like what happens if it
if it halts for
me. I did not run it with anything.
So
worker. It shouldn't matter. It should
be fine like this.
Multi. There should not be an issue with
this. This is weird.
Multiprocessing. You always had to have
two workers, two M's.
No, you can have as many as you want or
as few as you
want. The uh the new branches also will
have better warnings for like batch size
stuff as well.
doing? If it's done, it should just go
into starting. It It really shouldn't.
This is just taking
forever.
Before I pulled in dev, this was not a
an
issue. I guess we just like put some
break
points. But this is very
odd. Oh, wait. Is the policy kind of big
or the I mean not big enough where it
should be delaying like that.
Is the mini batch like ridiculous?
Like is this mini batch ridiculously
large?
is. Mini batch on default on mine is
8192,
but by
this if not, we'll start stepping
through this to see what the heck is
going
on. Clone agent
offset. So, this says that you have
4,9 4637 agents.
Um,
plus one more
round that the But that's not the number
that you told me.
No, the number I told you is
the is the actual number divided by
eight.
Well, no.
Like it's you if you have multiple
copies of the of M's that still counts.
Like those are all unique cars.
Um, like I I wanted to know the OBS
batch size. Is this like not the OBS
batch size?
The 500 something I told you earlier.
It's It's probably just not the OBS
batch size. No, it's 4,000 something.
Yeah. So then that's Yeah, it's totally
going to break because this is a dev
branch that doesn't have safety checks
on stuff not being divisible. So it's
probably just infinite looping somehow.
Um, I'm trying to get that number for
you right now. When I when I reloaded
the the levels, the numbers I was
working with changed. So, let
me Well, you will actually get warnings
about that on the release branch. Like,
it'll make sure everything's evenly
divisible. We're not even getting to run
the policy.
Okay, it's not even getting to evaluate.
So, something's just screwy.
It could be mad at what I
did, but like it looks like it's just
hanging in the
Go to native
then serial.
I've got a meeting, by the way, with the
the guys that I was uh the the tech guy
of the the guys that I chatted with you
about a few weeks ago at 4:15 if you
want to join. If not, I'll just handle.
Is that uh today or what? Yeah, in was
it a little under an hour? Okay. Oh,
your time 4:15. Okay. Okay.
Oh, yeah. I forgot there wasn't an hour
difference. Yeah. Yeah. I'm I'm in
central
You will appreciate the flag that's
going in the background then
in terms of like the num agents times 8
number
total agents equals 582 is what's being
returned. Yeah. So the times 8 is the
4656.
because I was cloning those just to try
and get more parallel going on 75. 48
was say 4856 40
4656. I don't think this is the error,
but we will fix this at least.
What if it's a torch
issue? be
weird. And then on reset is when it
loads all the maps or right
here. It loads all of them in the Syon,
but in a nit it does it
all. Wait, is that the right order?
Observations, actions, rewards, masks,
terminals. I think the order is wrong.
Oh, we probably check that.
Is that something with the new bindings?
Is that would be an issue? No, that's
just been like that
forever. Yeah, this this has
observations in it, man.
Um, hang
OBS actions rewards terminals.
Terminals then masks. There's not even a
masks in the Oh, I guess it depends on
if you actually if you put it in the
that order in the Syon, it's
um how do we get this to be a
reasonable number of
Um, how do we get this thing to be a
reasonable size?
What do you mean by that? Can we get
this to be a multiple
of 128 or something? Or not really? No,
it's entirely dynamic because it's based
on the amount of agents per map of those
maps that you're given.
I mean, you could
technically reduce the amount of static
cars in a map. Or no, hold up. Because
you only care about active cars. You You
just be taking out some active cars
theoretically. Okay, let me see if I can
hack this thing then. Like, but that
would be a little
jank. If I can hack this thing.
Like if I just comment this, does it
run?
I mean, I think to get it to at least a
less annoying place, maybe getting rid
of my cloning in the Sython would
probably make things a little less. It's
just that we're shipping we're shipping
Huda stuff now and it's
like it doesn't like when things aren't
fixed sizes. There's technically I can
make it work. Just I haven't done it
yet. Let me see if this breaks or not.
kernels. Oh, now it's rea tuning. Takes
forever.
Yep. So that's not It's just not happy.
It's just not
happy. It's the Okay. Is it cuz it's
over
4096? Hang
on. I mean
I just
do see if I do this good for
To be fair, the mini batch size doesn't
have to be this way.
Maybe this is the trick.
Are you just forcing the mini batch to
be a good number? Six.
16k like you see the issue is like the
CUDA kernels they expect like a certain
number of rows. Mhm.
Maybe this is the this is the thing
though. We just let you
do different mini batch size compared to
batch
size because we no longer like iterate
through anymore. We sample
anyways. So maybe that's the play. You
have to be kind of careful with your
batch size, but you don't have to really
care about the mini batch size. As long
as it's like
a big enough that
advantage. I
mean, it's still not going to let me
compute. It's this one
I just want to get you like a version of
this that you can play with and solve
the problem
on. And then like it'll be on me to
figure out what we're going to
do longer
term to like make this thing not such a
pain in the
ass whether that's figuring out how to
make the CUDA kernels run better and
yeah there here.
So, is that an assert or was that not
an? We got some weird message up there.
It's
happy. Wait,
Spencer, why did you do
You did eight replicas and and you but
you put them on the same core instead of
doing it on multiple cores.
If you get rid of that, I think it drops
down to like 17% of time or something
like that.
Well, that doesn't make sense because
it's 8x more data. The problem is it's
on one core, right? But I thought GP I
thought the thing was fast. Is it not?
So, it's at
like end time ranges from like 700,000
to a million steps per second. But the
train if you get all of the obs in there
whether they're really required or not.
Okay. So this is the thing I was saying
where it's like if we want this thing to
just work we should just respawn the
cars.
Okay. Actually here this is this is
working though. Here let's let's at
least get a reasonable setup out of
this. Um yeah. So, so what that right
now is your penalties right there. But I
I all I want to do is like
where's this factor? Where's this factor
of eight coming in? Syon. In the Sython.
In the Sython.
Eight. If I just look for eight.
Yeah, you'll find it. I see
UTF8. Num clones equals one.
Num clones is eight.
Okay. And then you hold up hold you have
to do one more thing. What else? Uh you
have to go inside of step and
reset in the Sython and change the times
8 because that variable wasn't defined
in
uh I only defined it in in it.
Okay, why don't we actually use our CPU
which has multiple cores.
Actually, let's do that. I I didn't do
it at first because I felt like whenever
I did multiprocessing, I was getting
weirdly
less successful results and I didn't
know if it was just because of like how
my like agent setups were. Well, we will
find that
out. This is spamming way faster.
Whoa. That total agent. Now you're only
going to have like 500 something agents.
No, because I have eight I'm doing this
eight
times on eight different processes. I'm
doing the same thing that you're doing.
So instead of making eight copies of one
process,
right? Right.
Okay. Why is this a total O agents
32,000? Did it not recompile? Is there a
factor of eight somewhere still?
drive.py. Numb agents. Total agents
times 8.
We just doubled the training speed.
Yeah. And if you if you take out some of
the obs, I mean, then you you drop you
can increase it even more. I was really
I only really slowed things down because
I was getting I was confused as to why I
couldn't get something that was matching
exactly. So I was like, "Okay, maybe
it's something to do with the ops." So,
I decided to just copy exactly what
there was, even though I know it really
shouldn't affect it,
but I use this.
So, so this is also the zero penalty
test. So, this test should always get
you to pretty much um 99 point, you
know, like 99 if it's has zero um
penalty collisions on off-road or
hitting a car. Okay. So, why is it not
instant solving this if it's easy? It
generally for me took about 100 million
steps to get to 0.99.
Uh, I'm used to things running 10x this
fast. So, it's still at 15 mil.
Yeah, there's a lot of speed loss
getting from environment to polic to the
the torch side of things.
The ops are huge.
And then I added the one hot encoding on
on the classifications of the roads.
So this shared embedding what is hang on
where's the one that has the max on it.
If you go into the encode observations
the maxes are on the road and the
partner
features. Okay. And those go to input
size, which is
uh 128,
which is what the NYU group had. All
right. I kind of want to up your hidden
size, but we'll
see. We actually have we have um I
believe 512 hidden dim with a simple
policy.
This This one's pretty cool. Uh so grid
here has a 512 hidden dim RNN. It's like
a 2 mil perm policy or whatever. Transit
1.8 million steps a second.
but ob's really small on grid, right?
Mhm.
It's not terrible. It's just it
Mhm. It's not terrible. It's just it feels slow because it's training slow.
feels slow because it's training slow.
Yeah,
but this is without collisions,
correct?
It's my it's it's my sanity test just to
make sure that it can actually get to
the goal and like figure out that
portion because I was like, why is this
not figuring it out with collisions?
And does it get reward for hitting goal
or what does it get? Yeah, just gets
reward for hitting goal the same way
that they've set up
theirs and you get one
reward. It it it's kind of down to like
an entropy thing at some point because
it's like it has to find the
goal, but if it's having to find it and
it's hitting walls the whole time
getting there, it it tends to find it to
be kind of a random luck event. Have you
seen how Puffer handles random luck
events?
This is kind of the best that there is
in RL right
now with this maze
finding. Like we're pretty good at that.
This kind of just works out of the box.
Look, it actually even solves this one.
Like that's why I feel like this
shouldn't be a challenging it problem.
It shouldn't.
cuz the environment's fast enough where
it should be able to
just get there. You would think it's
possible the hypers are just bad. I
don't know. Let's see what your hypers
are. I mean, they're just default
hypers, I think. I mean, oh, see if that
is true.
Your learning rate is your learning rate
is 5x lower than mine.
What about
grid? We
do 05 for
grid. But in grid, we have a way bigger
policy than you have.
Why is your entropy coefficient?
Hey, no mind the entropy coefficient.
I don't know. We just It's not even a
fully tuned run is the thing. I kind of
just threw partial defaults on stuff and
kind of so everything.
That's the crazy thing. It's like we're
not even remotely close to like this is
not even my final form, right?
Let me try and link you as well.
Uh previous runs that I've gotten
to I'm going to just like make the
policy bigger after this.
Um, it looks like one of the runs where
I got to 99 pretty quickly, or at least
relatively quickly speaking, was with a
kneeling on.
Yeah, this has a kneeling on
with a higher default learning rate.
Yeah, this is like 5x too low. I think I
just had the original one that you had
the 025 when I had purely the original
defaults. Mhm. It got there
in 15 minutes. In 15
minutes. Oh, but you were using ultra
slow version. Yeah. I mean, maybe it'll
be
like five minutes or something.
Five minutes. Still slow.
I did the maze policy trained in 90
seconds and it's bigger.
I am all here if you're able to get this
to go to the the
902. Oh, I'll definitely be able to.
It's just a matter of
um I mean, ideally I get this ideally I
want to get this merged onto I know it's
a pain in the ass to keep up with my
release branches, but it does make it
easier to test [ __ ] Um
I mean for a while you said to just not
touch the new dev branch for a while
too. Yeah, I think also was that around
when because I knew I was going to be
gone for a week and wasn't going to be
able to help you either. Yeah, it so
this is just like, hey, I just merged
it. I'm going to throw this in your
direction.
We will see what uh what magic I can
apply to this.
It does not seem to be doing 99 or
whatever. It seems to be stuck at 80
something.
It's probably because the learning rate
there. I mean that that was just a
recent learning rate I just dropped on
there. If you put it back to the the
original 1025, it probably can solve
it. Okay. So, can I
um Yeah, fine. We'll do 25. We'll do one
more experiment on this. But then what
about the This is with the freaking
collisions off like correct.
It's kind of ridiculous.
Yeah. It's lame. Yeah.
And this should just be solved by now.
Um,
with collisions on one of the things of
a recent run I got, but it took a while.
I just put it in the chat was this run.
Yeah, if you have existing experiments,
I'm actually going to be able to give
you feedback on stuff. Let me go
slow8? Why is there so this is with
collisions? That's with collisions. So
score, which is you the percentage of
time that the agents reach their goal,
give collision rate and then off-road
rate. Your collision rate goes down,
right? But it's not as good as theirs.
Theirs is like less than 1%. Yeah, but
you're not solving the freaking task
yet, man.
Yeah, but there's also got there at a
time where in terms of the steps would
have already achieved it because they
have a bunch of annoying policy
differences
though. They've got like a bunch of
layer norms and weird stuff.
True, but should it not just do? No,
it'll be we got to sweep stuff and it's
like, okay, you're you're now operating
within like a margin of like fiddly
stuff is possible and just like run more
experiments. Um, like get this thing be
first, then we'll worry about whether
this thing actually is not there still.
Because if you look at the time, I mean,
that's like an hour, but even then,
yeah, it's an hour cuz it's freaking
slow. This is less than a tenth of the
speed of our other
Ms. This should This would be 6 minutes.
True.
We got to fix that
[ __ ] I mean, this is not even async
right
here. I I just did this. I got I This is
2.6x the speed of this run, and I didn't
even do
Yeah.
So, I mean, we this should be able to be
something reasonable. And then also, we
can play around. I'd be happy if it was
in like the 600 to 750 range at this
point. But, I mean, we Your obs are
freaking like the thing is the obs are
just big.
If we can get this version to
a successful result, I'm very confident
we can kill a lot of the obs and
probably get something comparable. Okay,
let's then let's do
this. Got boxes. Let's throw some stuff
at things. All right, let's see what we
have in our
uh not this one. Where did the GP drive
go?
Yeah. Okay.
So, that's that doesn't actually
Okay. So, input size to the RNN's got to
be
512.
Well, let's let's get this to run.
And we're gonna like let's actually get
a real
policy because okay when I was doing
although not the smartest approach the
8x cloning on a single core this was the
policy that I
got I just linked to you in chat and it
was a pretty smooth train curve.
What did what was
this? This is the one that I that is uh
pretty much default params
um but with the 8x
clone on one
core. Weird.
I guess it's possible there's a
multipprocessing difference. I haven't
seen it on anything else.
Okay, here's your thing running at
basically the exact same speed as
before.
Um, but with a 2 million parameter
policy. How was it running at the same
speed?
You're completely freaking bound by M's
and communication and [ __ ] This is
not the right one, I don't think,
though, because it doesn't this doesn't
look
right. What's What's going on with
this? Not 84 score, right? I'm looking
at it right
Where's my freaking run? Did I not I
guess it's not on Neptune. Yeah. Okay.
So, 4 at 10
mil. Oh, that might be still be
comparable.
You have zero reward for collision, zero
off-road.
Did you want to reset your learning rate
to the default?
No, this is what we use for this size
policy. So, here's your next train.
Where is
it? Okay, there it is.
See what this does. Does my torch even
use the hidden size variable? Do I not
just use input size on everything? No,
you use it. You use hidden
Okay. I did it for the shared layer at
the very end. Yeah. Which is all because
then that goes into the main network,
right?
I mean, I could like there are like
several improvements I could make to
this as
well potentially.
Okay. I mean, this is doing something,
right?
potentially. Let's see what other things
you have going on
here. Got learning rate
set batch size. batch
size. Have you tried Have you messed
with gamma lambda at all?
Not beyond me just having a sweep a
while back ago.
What gamma and lambda did you get out of
it?
Um, pull up my
sweep cuz the default gamma is really
freaking high.
This is doing way better though. You
see,
uh, it looks like my highest gamma on
that best run was fairly low. Actually,
it was
point Never mind. I was looking at the
wrong uh.99 and 0.987.
Okay. So, that's not that far off of
what we have. That's
0.995. I'm hoping this just gives us a
better rain
curve. It should just get to
0.99. Mhm. If with the additional
network capacity it doesn't, then
there's going to be some something
weird.
and these offsets in here haven't
changed,
I don't think anything should have
changed
I did notice my active agents count
changed fairly recently with that's the
other thing is we're not masking stuff
at all. Like the thing that made the GPU
drive uh their GPU drive stuff work very
very well was like the masked
No, this has mask in right now. Yeah,
but our code doesn't fix like doesn't
use it correctly in the new version.
Oh, yeah. Oh, in the latest dev version.
know what you're saying. Mhm. Uh
this is going to be massively easier if
we just respawn the [ __ ] cars. I'm
telling you,
and then just have them try and avoid
not spawning on top of a car that's
where in the path of where another car
is.
Don't even bother doing that. Literally
just like cuz they they don't bounce off
each other. They just get a negative
reward. Right. Correct. Okay. completely
ignore the fact that that can happen.
Respawn the cars where they're supposed
to start whenever they either get to
their objective or or
collide. So collide equals negative
reward and respawn.
Okay. Guarantee you it's so much it's
going to be so much easier.
All right. Well, that's an easy change.
Yeah, it's not that hard of a change.
And it's like, well, it's not realistic.
Well, it's not realistic to have the
cars freaking phase through each other
either, right? It's like arguably this
is more realistic cuz if you've crashed,
you've already screwed up.
Okay. Okay. I'll take that logic. Yes.
And now here, uh, we are doing better
than before.
So, yeah, it took me three experiments
to fix this mostly.
And the way that I knew what to do is
because I just did the exact same thing
that worked on every other
environment. That's all I
did. I should try this on breakout to be
fair. I have not done that
yet. Bigger network to see if I can
install
it.
So, I don't know if we're getting N9 out
of this. We will see. We're definitely
doing better than before.
But hey, look, this is like
substantially better than before. I cut
your error rate in half pretty
much. Assuming this gets a little bit
better than this. When is gym stream?
Gymstream is between all other things
I'm doing while streaming. I just get up
and use equipment. But you will see many
pieces of equipment be delivered over
the next few
weeks. We have, I think, two orders that
should be coming in either end of this
week, start of next week, and then
there's a big order that should be
coming in in a few weeks.
And then the thing I'm still waiting on
is terrace to go down so I can order all
of the servers for the racks behind
Okay. So, I'm trying to think how I give
this to I think I just push this to a
new branch for
you. That sound good. I just pushed this
to a new branch for you. You can like
just make those changes, push to this
branch and see that it solves
everything.
I suspect the encoder layer should also
probably be bigger.
you're running these on. Yeah, you have
at least eight cores to run stuff
on. So, yeah, there you
go. That ought to be decent for you.
still doesn't get to max. But like just
fix the masking
Sorry, I had to take a quick phone call.
Mhm. Um, okay. So, you pushed up to
Huffer Drive GitHub
Huffer Drive branch. It actually gets
89%.
Okay.
It looks like it's still doing a little
bit of stuff.
So, turn off
um
masking, turn on uh
respawning and take it from there.
So, when they collide or reach the
goal, they should
respawn at the start. If they hit the
goal, they get the plus goal reward. If
they collide, they get the minus collide
reward. Yeah, sure. So, run
that and you should just
solve. Like, it's an inf it's a pure
infrastructure limitation. The old
infrastructure could handle this, but
the new infrastructure is like
dramatically better algorithmically.
Okay. Um, I can do that. And then
you want me to sit on the call with
these with the upcoming call with the
415 one? Yeah, we can tell them just
like to make this thing quick.
And then um after that, do we want to
keep working on this or uh can you How
long is it going to take you to make
those changes?
I don't think it should take me any time
at all, honestly. All right, do that
real quick. I'm go use the restroom. Go
do that stuff real quick and then we'll
I'll start working on this with you as
soon as you have that stuff ready
because I think it's like this version
it's just you're fighting the
infrastructure and I don't want to be
wasting our time running experiments
when it's like going to be so so so much
easier. So this thing it looks like it's
crashing now.
Uh which is like it's actually something
I have to deal with with the analing. I
figured it out. But this got to 91 92
before that. So, okay. Well, um yeah,
just go ahead and just um I don't know.
Are you hopping on a Google call? What
are you doing? Are you paying?
Whatever it is, I'll get you an invite.
All right, sounds good. And I'll just
send you on Discord. Sounds good. All
right. See you,
Spencer.
Cool. All right. So, uh here's the uh
the plan, folks.
I gotta go take a call in a few.
Um, oh, we have quite a few folks on
here. Hey everyone on Twitch. If you
haven't been around here before,
uh, I do hyper reinforcement learning
dev. It's all open source. It's all
free. You can see a bunch of demos at
puffer.ai. And, uh, you know, Spencer's
just a collaborator who came in with no
RL experience. That could be you. you're
interested in getting
involved. If you want to help me out for
free, just star the GitHub. Really helps
when we get stars on GitHub. Uh and you
can join the Discord to get involved
with
dev. Cool. So, here's the plan.
Um we're going to keep fixing GPU drive
stuff today. Driving sim. Actually, I
can show this off real quick. Why
not? We have the EVEL, I think, working,
right?
sim. Pretty
cool.
Um, so the plan here is going to be to
fix this with Spencer today. We also
have hyperparam tuning algorithm stuff
to
fix. That's my alarm to get ready for
meeting. Um, we're going to do all that.
I got to
take a quick meeting and then I'll be
back for probably an hour after that
before 6 and then I should be back after
dinner for a little bit more work things
pending and then I'm pretty much live
all day every day otherwise. So, uh,
yeah, thanks for tuning in